Yeah, so church, it is a joy every time we get to do this,
whether it's the beginning or the end, we had a
baptism in the first service as well, one
of our high school boys.
And so we're thankful that God is continuing to work.
And so we get to celebrate this
because it's a picture of salvation in
what God's done in someone's life.
And so we get to celebrate with the leveraged family today.
This is Claire, and she's coming to be There you go.
They're on the front row. We said that. Yep.
So we are praising God for what he has done in her life as,
uh, the family points their kids to Jesus.
The church comes alongside and helps do that as well.
And she's just come to that place to see
that she needs a savior and has confessed him as Lord been
transformed from the inside out.
This today is a picture of that in obedience to
what Jesus commanded to do.
And so because of your profession of faith, I get
to baptize you in the name of the Father,
son and Holy Spirit.
Yep. Let's pray. Let's pray. God, thank you for Claire.
Thank you for the, the work you've done in her life.
That this picture of death to life, of burial,
to resurrection is
what you've done already in her heart forever.
Thank you for that, and I pray that you continue
to push her forward towards you.
Draw her heart to faith more every day, to deep obedience,
more every day, to trust you in the hard times,
more every day, to see the goodness of God more every day.
Help us as a church to do that well, as her parents
and others around and her family do that.
Lord, I pray that you would use her life
for your glory in huge ways.
In Jesus' name, amen.
Amen. Amen. You may.